herr bosbach was haben sie als erstes
gedacht als sie gestern abend von dem
anschlag in wien gehört haben wie alle
anderen auch habe ich natürlich sofort
an die opfer des anschlags gedacht an
ihrer angehörigen an die ungewissheit
für diejenigen die freunde bekannte
familienmitglieder in der nähe der
tatorte vermutet haben
und dann gingen die gedanken natürlich
sofort nach frankreich obwohl wir zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch zu wenige
informationen haben um sicher sein zu
können ob es da verbindungen gibt oder
nicht die ideologischen verbindungen die
gibt es auf jeden fall
und auch wir in deutschland können
leider nicht davon ausgehen dass der
islamistisch motivierte terror einen
bogen um unseren dank machen wird zumal
auch wir schon zu oft ziel von
islamistischen attentätern waren sie
haben es gerade angesprochen erst mit
sei jetzt wie das ist ja auch eine
zeitliche geringe abfolge jetzt haben
sie auch gerade die situation bei uns
angesprochen was schätzen sie denn wie
hoch ist die gefahr aktuell bei uns dass
so etwas auch bei uns passiert das
bundeskriminalamt weiß seit jahren
darauf hin dass wir eine angespannte
sicherheitslage haben auch wenn ich gehe
mal davon aus das gilt auch jetzt für
den start heute keine konkreten hinweise
auf einen zeitpunkt und den ort eines
anschlags in deutschland geben könnte
aber allein die hohe zahl von mehreren
hundert gefährdern und relevanten
personen aus diesem islamistischen
terroristischen spektrum die sich in
deutschland aufhalten müssen wir leider
davon ausgehen dass es eines tages auch
uns wieder treffen kann
würden sie diese abende sind dafür
gerüstet diese anschläge zu verhindern
also gerade nach dem fürchterlichen
attentat auf dem breitscheidplatz haben
die sicherheitsbehörden ihrer
anstrengung und noch einmal sehr erhöht
nur gibt es wahrscheinlich noch zu oft
folgenden irrtum der islamische staat
ist zwar in seinem haupt siedlungs
gebieten in syrien oder im irak
militärisch besiegt worden aber die
ideologie lebt
sie lebt fort in gruppen in zellen aber
auch in radikalisierten einzeltätern und
auch der tod des anführers al baghdadi
hat ja nicht dazu geführt dass wir davon
ausgehen können dass sich die
terrorgefahr die vom islamischen staat
ausgeht deutlich verringert hat und
deshalb ist es auch wichtig dass wir
unsere polizei den rücken stärken und
mir nicht in den rücken fallen
auch in wien waren dass polizistinnen
und polizisten die ihr leben riskiert
haben um die bevölkerung vor diesen
mördern zu schützen und herr bosbach was
glauben sie warum wurde gerade wien als
anschlagsziel ausgesucht das ist reine
spekulation das ist eine gute frage in
den ersten nachrichten kamen hier auch
der verdacht auf dass möglicherweise die
in der nähe der tatorte gelegenen
jüdische synagoge ein ziel sein könnte
das wissen wir jetzt noch nicht so wie
wir auch nicht wissen war es ein
einzeltäter waren es mehrere täter
wer sind die anstifter die gehilfen die
geistige brandstifter die zwar nicht
selber den finger am abzug haben aber
die durch ihre ideologie dafür sorgen
dass dieser mörderische waren sich in
taten ausdrückt wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren